longtime friend and a longtime friend of
the program go in and he's kind enough
to call in after his in big enshrinement
weekend Pro Football Hall of Famer Brian
honor like her
how does that sound here Brian sounds
good and I'm very excited to be a member
of that uh luscious group there all
right what was it like now looking back
just first blush first first date hectic
just you know it's such a world when you
get big I got on Wednesday and he just
don't stop going the whole time there's
you ghost one thing to the next as you
can tell my voice is still kind of
hoarse so while we're talking I was
doing all weekend but people are so
appreciative the people in Ken they're
unbelievable I hear welcome home you can
one more time and pull my hair yeah cuz
you mean you do shake everybody's hand I
mean you meet the entire town pretty
really do it they embrace the Hall of
Fame that it's really it's really cool
to see you know they mean it when they
say that you welcome home they mean it
they don't just say it to say they mean
it and it really comes across that way
what was it like I mean let's put it
this way LaDainian Tomlinson said his
aha moment he said every hall-of-famer
has an aha moment where they realize
that this is different
he said his is when Jim Brown sat next
to him at the state of the hall speech
last year what was yours did you have
one this weekend when mom was playing at
the luncheon on Friday I mean they have
the Hall of Fame luncheon ashes whole
thing was only English sitting there Joe
Namath speaking Chris Carter's walking
around Michael Irvin speak and there's
always fights 20 guys that spoke and he
just sitting there listening like damn
on in the room with all these guys you
know you just it's just guys you never
thought you'd be have a chance to be in
that eternity you know it was so cool to
be in there listen to what they had to
say there's a lot of different topics
that came up but that was probably when
they hit me in Friday night at the gold
jacket dinner outside together cool
jacket you know when I walked through
the counter gallant there to get to the
stage another time to get me their
churches and it's probably three or four
over the course of the weekend they have
you pretty hard
and what about closer to you
professional home but guests being there
Dick Butkus yeah be in there did you
have any conversation with him special
chit chit chat bears chit chat with him
not much don't you talk a little bit at
luncheon on Friday and then I saw him
did I see him I think I saw him right
before I guys sat down on stage as the
guy introduced for for the ceremony
he walked by goes to play pretty honor
any kid that's what he said it's pretty
hot in the kid he's got a such a great
humor you know I've known him for about
15 years others you gotta get him you
know he's a he's well but here's a funny
funny sense of humor I mean he's been
there and done that did bucko I know yes
you know and you know and I'm sure again
that you you have had experiences with
him but never where you both have a
jacket man
I mean that's incredible you both one of
the best of all time obviously we know
that but you know you look at our
tradition at the bearish man bill George
I said this unless he's bill George big
buckets mike singletary nominee is just
it's unbelievable the great linebackers
we've had you know and I'll be honest
with you Brian people talk and and and
not like lay money down but make wagers
as to who's gonna be the one to cry
first okay I heard your name a lot Brian
throughout the weekend and you you
almost paid off that bet you were almost
the first one to go when you mentioned
your mom I mean that guess everybody but
you were there almost the first to go
Brian I know but I was well the bad
thing was I was the first of the
modern-day guys to go that's right the
older guys are all tough I'm not crying
for cities my good been high game was
gonna cry Robert you're not gonna cry
but man it's hard because you know
there's people you know obviously my mom
and my kids you know I'm looking at my
Adam and I could the thing that saved me
they goodness was in my life especially
to the franceour was next to them so I
was looking at the prompter and not add
them because if I'm seeing them I'm
losing it for sure I'm definitely gonna
cry so I was able to not look right at
them when I spoke to them
Brian Urlacher here on the Rich Eisen
show and the kind of you saw today part
of the conversation is that the hall may
require future eligible players when
they're named as a semifinalist to
declare that they're going to show up to
the Canton otherwise they're not going
to be allowed in
if that's any would you agree with
something like that fine the whole thing
is such a big debate because all team is
nothing to do to get you in anyway right
it's all about who votes the media votes
so now you're gonna take it out and I
mean once the media votes you in and
you're pretty much in because you know
everyone always debates on why they why
they should be able to vote for us to be
in and then if you don't get in you
blame them I think it and you thank them
whatever but why should the whole be
able to keep you out now yes they loaded
you in you know it's always been that
way that when they said when I vote you
in and you get 80% of the votes you're
in well I guess the part of this is that
they wouldn't even let you be voted on
again this is it's it's not it's not
official this is not official this is
rumor I've yet to be able but you're
still saying you're gonna go in and not
go you know it there's no clear there's
no clear way to solve that problem in my
opinion you know there's a little bit of
data over that at the luncheon on Friday
as well this is a tough situation some
people are gonna do what they think is
right how spirited was that debate I
don't want to put you in a position
where you're telling us out of school a
moment for a minute I'm very interesting
conversation though I was glued to
everyone who was talking I'll tell you
that much it was nice to hear both sides
it's amazing those guys get in the room
everybody's got an opinion in there you
know as I said in the previous segment
that's the Alpha the alpha male group
all you guys but you know what's crazy
about that room is most of the egos
Billy does at the door when they walk in
there you know there's not a lot of
sounds like there's people trying to
outdo somebody else in there it's just
people speak about somewhere I said
people talk about how they saw they
speak how they feel and there's no you
know some grudges there's no ill feeling
so when people say what they think and
you move on that's all there is to it
well I mean cuz you're all Ingles you're
only queer are equals and that's what
they reiterated in there as well we're
all the same that we're all the same
classes no one's better than anybody
else but all at the same level and
that's why I think it's cool about the
Hall of Fame
whether you're a first valid fifth valid
20th ballot doesn't matter you're in the
Hall of Fame it doesn't matter when you
go in Brian Urlacher here a couple more
minutes so let's let's talk about the
elephant in the room
I'm certainly only alerting you know
last time last time that we had a
conversation you you gave me a heads up
and literally figuratively that your
choice of bust would be the brawl the
bald Brian Urlacher and abroad you have
welcomed people yeah the bald and
beautiful Brian earlier yeah you went
ahead and did that so your immortality
is is enshrined oh yeah are you fine
with that you deal with gray was that I
played my whole career bald man I uh you
know I said this before rich I got a
good ball shaped head so my dude Ben who
did the bus did a good job
I feel like it looks pretty much just
like me yes as you know I think he did a
good job well I had it's hard to hard to
recreate but he did a good job I don't
mean to correct you it looks like you
used to be used to be Brian yes you were
bald
uh-huh but not anymore I know you do and
I gotta tell you now you know we go back
and forth about this for the first time
I saw I saw for the first time I'm very
impressed very impressed well you know
just look now so I have a just now I see
it takes to reap all the like is okay so
I'm just you know I'm just used to it
and then it's a tradition unlike any
other in our conversations Brian
I said I'll bring this up to the players
the players that you mentioned you did
who did snub them
you didn't mention you didn't make all
right rich I spell tons of players you
know I was trying to be respectful of
everyone else's time mmm during my
speech for that was the first one to go
the modern guys so there are some
teammates and coaches and friends that
got left out I know I regretted that
when I was done but I felt like it was
the right thing to do for me to be
respectful of the guys behind me their
time to to just make mine you know the
length of speech that we were asked to
make it I understand I understand yeah I
was I was a little disappointed there
was no mention of Jay Cutler Brian
Urlacher you know I was like three four
years ago just making sure I got the
guys I played with for a long time in
there any guys that's a big impact on my
career
just like the top of your head that's a
good cover story Brian it's a very good
cover story is great seeing your
beautiful wife your beautiful family
just your speech was beautiful the whole
damn weekend was beautiful and and just
I couldn't be happier for you Brian
the world won but it was fun my hopes
man so we went to bed at 5:30 than one
so my party was Thursday night my kids
stayed the whole time the whole party
till 5:30 we left the hotel
at 5:30 got home you know I woke up at
9:00 to some stuff so they stuck to like
one yesterday on the plane I hope my son
was crashed the whole way too hard
that's a beautiful part of the weekend
it's just from beginning end it's just
it just is a warm feeling and then when
you come back next year you don't have
any of that pressure to bring everybody
in your life and make a speech yeah
that's just like keep their necks to be
able to enjoy it just kind of wash and
take it all in and play some golf and
hang out but that's the beautiful thing
again is that in terms of not that's
what I said at the beginning the show
instead of paying attention as to who's
not there just keep coming back Brian
you coming back every year that's how
this this this event stays relevant you
agreed keep coming back
yes most of our class a little mealy huh
it's unbelievable
oh man some good dudes in there Kramer I
would love to just you know sit back and
take off with him he has some great I
sent the rooms in a desert on Friday for
probably 15 minutes I say a word I just
listened I mean they're just took their
stories and they remember every detail
it's amazing listen to them talk and
Bobby that's activity when it's Weiss
guys I've ever met that's great Brian
thanks thanks for calling in have a
great time and we'll chat we'll catch up
soon okay
all right thanks all right that's Brian
Urlacher Hall of Famer the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience